- You posted a photo though
with a guy we both love.
I love Snoop.
- [Rose] Come on.
- [Kelly] I forgot that
y'all had worked together.
- [Rose] Oh yeah.
- This was back in the day, right?
Like when was this?
- What's not to love about Snoop?
- I love him.
You're always gonna have a good time.
- You're always gonna have a time.
We did this little indie
movie called "The Tenants."
I'm like 20 like three.
I dunno, I'm so young.
And I played his girlfriend
and he was such a gentleman.
We had like a dancing scene.
He told me I had good moves.
I asked him, "Should I
call you Snoop or Calvin?"
He said, "My mother calls me Calvin.
You can call me Snoop."
- Oh, he saves up for his mama.
- I was like, yeah.
I was like, cute.
And then at the end he
gave me a huge blunt.
This massive joint.
- How was it?
- Oh, I didn't go near it.
I was like, I'll never, I won't recover.
I was like, I can't.
So I gave it to my friend.
- Oh my God, did your friend freak out?
- They said they had a good time.
- Yeah.
- They had a really good time.
- Yeah, I imagine.
Look, if you're gonna take
something from someone,
that would the...
- Fantastic.
It was like really brown paper.
I still remember how kind of
sophisticated this joint looked
compared to my, okay.
- Do you regret not just trying a little?
- Maybe I do, Kelly, you know what I mean.
Now that I'm thinking back, I'm like,
is that a missed?
That's definitely a missed opportunity.
- It's a missed story, at least.
- Yeah, it's a missed story.
- Just one puff.
I'm just saying like if Willie Nelson
or Snoop Dogg hands you something.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
I don't know guys.
- Has he given you one?
- No, I'm very jealous.
But he did give me,
we worked together and he gave
me this beautiful necklace.
It was beautiful.
- Oh, that's romantic.
- Well, it wasn't,
it wasn't in a weird way.
It was like in a, no, it was just very,
he's very nice.
- [Rose] Yeah.
- And he's like the best hype guy ever.
He makes you feel so
great about everybody.
- Hype man, yeah yeah yeah.
- He makes everybody feel so great.
- He was cool.
- Because he feels
really good all the time.
- And he's feeling good.
You feel the feels.
- Yeah, it was funny though,
'cause we worked together
and he just disappears
like every once in a while.
- Yeah, yeah,
yeah, and the trailer is just a huge...
- And he walks back in and you're like
I know where you've been.
- I know.